nft i don't know what that [ __ ] is i  think that's  i think that stands for nothing [ __ ]  there because uh  i don't know what the hell is going on  with an nft  i pretend to get it i don't get it i'm  old i'm gay i'm moving on what's that  dmt oh [ __ ] all right  we got a real drug addict in the back  here  look i don't know about nft i don't know  about dmt all i got is hpv and i'm  moving on okay  yeah  what about immigration where are you  guys at on that  hey yeah i like immigration you know  whoa built the wall jesus christ out boy  all right we might have a [ __ ] civil  war in here  i think i think that was the  anti-abortion guy too i mean  what happened sir were you supposed to  be aborted how'd you get by huh all  right  that guy was dodging coat hangers in  there huh holy [ __ ] whoa all right  somebody tased that [ __ ]